from his humble roots in searchlight to
the spotlight of capitol hill
his entire life was defined by defying
long odds
political leaders and family gathering
throughout the day to pay their respects
to former senate majority leader harry
reid as he lay in state as at the u.s
capitol good evening and thanks for
joining us here at five o'clock i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis lying
in state is an honor reserve for those
who perform remarkable service to our
nation washington correspondent basil
john joining us now live with today's
tribute basil
well denise bryan good evening and yes
the former nevada senator was referred
to as a legendary leader who was defined
as a soft-spoken and dedicated lawmaker
a somber atmosphere in the capital
rotunda as lawmakers paid tribute to
former nevada senator and senate
majority leader harry reid few have
shaped the workings of this building
like our dear friend from nevada senate
majority leader chuck schumer praised
the positive influence reid had on the
country other lawmakers and himself i
quickly learned
that even though harry talked softly
what he said
carried the force of thunder
he was honest
he was direct
and he was original he conquered
the impossible
and he made the world a better place
house speaker nancy pelosi emphasized
the love reid had for his home state
over his entire career he fought
tirelessly for nevada in every possible
way both democratic leaders humorously
recalled the late senator's habit to
hang up the phone at the end of the
conversation he doesn't say goodbye just
hung up he's not mad at you i probably
hold the record for being hung up on
more than anybody later in the day
president biden made a special trip from
the white house to the capitol to honor
his friend with an unforgettable senate
legacy harry was a guardian and a
steward of the senate
literally and figuratively
now the service was closed to the public
due to covet 19 protocols but colleagues
staff and others were able to visit
throughout the day reporting live in
washington i'm basil john
and basil really very few senators get
this level of honor
yes that is correct uh actually from
what we know uh he's only the 15th
senator to receive this honor and his
casket was actually rested on the
cataphalc that was used by former
president abraham lincoln so truly an
honor for him that it was basil thank
you for your report
our state's leaders also showing their
respect senator catherine cortez masto
posting this picture of her and senator
jackie rosen taking a moment there
beside the casket after senator reid's
passing late last month rosen took to
the senate floor to share a happy memory
he was a voice for all nevadans and if
you ever went to an event for senator
reid
he would remind you by making sure
home means nevada that's our state song
it was sung in honor of our beloved
state
she says he was a source of inspiration
and pride as well as a mentor and a
friend to many people in the chamber